As we saw in the last lecture.
The recent history of humans is one
of spreading across the planet and
encountering different diets and
different pathogens as they spread.
They also changed for random
reasons genetically as a result,
patients very genetically and ability
to resist infectious disease and in
susceptibility to degenerative diseases.
Because of this recent
evolutionary history,
there were observations quite a while
back that suggested that people very
genetically and their susceptibility to
disease children are at greater risk of
succumbing to an infectious disease if
one of their parents had it for several
diseases that include TB
and bacterial meningitis.
Many are infected but few gets sick,
so some are resistant.
People living in an area where a disease
is endemic are often more resistant
than those in a region where the disease
is not exist indicating that there's
some local adaptation to disease.
No.
There are a number of approaches to
find genes for disease resistance.
The first is the candidate gene approach
and this is the older of the two
approaches. For example, a
combination of biological insight,
biochemistry cell biology was used
to identify sickle cell anemia,
other hemoglobin variants that
confirmed malaria resistance.
The more recent approaches a genome
wide association studies g was,
so these are based on single nucleotide
polymorphisms and whole genome sequences
and they have suggested
many more candidate genes,
most of which have much smaller effects
than those that were identified with
Kennedy gene approaches.
Okay.
Some of the susceptibility genes that
were discovered with Kennedy gene
approaches are two major diseases.
And let's first take a
look at the diseases.
So we can see here that out of this list
of six genes that have been identified,
four of them relate to malaria.
This is a real signal of how important a
selective agent malaria has been in the
recent human past.
Another is for quite filled yakoff
disease that is a prion disease.
Another is for HIV one,
so for the virus that causes AIDS,
that is a receptor called CCR five and
another is for Norwalk virus diarrhea.
And by the way,
it's not surprising that a gene providing
resistance to diarrhea would be on one
of the top lists because diarrhea is one
of the major causes of infant mortality
on the planet.
So here we have the
particular names of the genes,
both their uh,
acronym and the condition or the
variant that is associated with these.
And these were discovered
between 1954 and 2003.
One of the,
uh,
genetic systems that's implicated in
disease resistance is the blood Abo blood
group system.
For example,
people who are blood type
a are more susceptible and
people who are blood type o
are more resistant to
plasmodium falciparum.
That is the pathogen that causes
the Nastier type of malaria.
Okay.
People with blood type O on the other
hand are more susceptible and people with
blood type B are more
resistant to Norwalk virus.
And so these are both serious issues
and you can see here that there's a
tradeoff going on among
these genetic variants.
The one that's good for resisting one
disease is not good for resisting another.
Yeah.
Oh. And a are both more susceptible
to helix. Go back to Pylori,
which adheres to gastric epethelial
cells that use blood group antigens
associated with,
oh,
so people with type O are going to be
more susceptible to having a stomach
ulcers and gastric cancer.
Okay.
That blood group is more common in
isolated populations in central and South
American Indians.
Okay.
Susceptibility to syphilis collar
and play. Also the pen on Abo genes
and mutations can cause reduce secretion
of Abo into saliva and those that are
homozygous nonsecure heaters. There are
at higher risk of infectious disease.
For example, meningitis. However,
see critters are at higher risk of
upper respiratory tract infections,
so you can see that even within this
system just how much of it is expressed
leads to a tradeoff between susceptibility
to meningitis or upper respiratory
tract problems.
Yeah.
Here is an example of a g was result
to give you some familiarity with it.
What you see here on the x axis is
the DNA sequence along a particular
chromosome. This chromosome 18 and
these are positions in kilobytes,
so marching down the chromosome.
If this is 18,000 that means that we are
18 million positions from the beginning
of the chromosome and the black
dots and the colored dots.
Here are the probabilities that a
particular snip is associated with the
disease.
So the way this is done,
as you have a sample of people that do
or do not have the disease and do or do
not have the sniff and you marched
down in doing the analysis,
you go right down the chromosome
looking at each position and asking how
strongly is this position position
associated with the disease on the y axis,
what we have basically is the probability.
So the higher the position on the y axis,
the more significant the result is.
This result here with the purple dot
has a probability of being observed at
random of about one in a billion.
It's about actually a
third of one in a billion.
So this is a highly significant result
and as you go down the chromosome,
you can see that many of the
results are now highly significant.
And then suddenly when
you hit this position,
which has this particular
name for that snip,
you get a highly significant result.
Now
the other thing that you should note are
these green lines down here with these
little spikes in them.
These are recombination frequencies.
What they show basically is the chunk of
the chromosome which is associated with
the snip, so this area is
recombining fairly frequently here.
This one is certainly recombining
frequently in these somewhat less.
This particular snip therefore is strongly
associated with any gene that's in
this part of the chromosome and particular
one which is called Rbb p eight so it
is riding through the generations
and through many different people,
mostly in association with this gene.
So you can think of it.
You can think of the snip is a flag
planted into the chromosome that marks a
chunk of it,
which is reliably associated through
recombination events and continues to be
associated with it.
It is passed through parents and offspring
and descendants and this is the kind
of result that leads to the identification
of a gene associated with particular
illness by g was in particular.
This one is for tuberculosis and it
is using mostly results from people in
Africa
using that method.
Here is a list of genes for disease
resistance that were confirmed and then
extended by Ge was and up at the top.
Basically we can see many of
the ones we've seen before,
but then you can see that there are quite
a few others that have been added to
it.
And in addition we find protection for
particular variants against Noro virus
against leprosy, against
meningitis, against bacteremias.
Interestingly, there are one, two, three,
four entries here for leprosy indicating
how important leprosy has been as a
selective agent in recent human history.
So to summarize,
first on g was the sequencing of the
human genome made possible the development
of these Genome Wide Association Studies,
g was some only had had been identified
with significant impacts on important
common diseases.
However,
their effects sizes
are often fairly small.
We're not able to explain very much of
the susceptibility to those diseases
through genetic variation of this type.
There are causal links to the diseases
can be obscure and that means that the
promise of individual medicine based on
information and genetic sequences is not
yet really fully realized.
However,
the cost of sequencing a human
genome is dropping. Remarkably.
The white line here is Moore's law that
relates to the processing power of chips
and uh,
it has been dropping steadily.
This is a log scale here.
This is time along this axis.
And what you can see is that the cost
per genome was dropping about at the rate
of Moore's law up until about 2007.
And since then it's going much
faster. And in fact, in 2015,
one can sequence a human genome
for about a thousand to $1,500.
And that is putting whole genome
sequencing within the reach of clinical
medicine for individual patients,
for people who are in rich developed
countries and have good insurance support.
So to summarize,
as humans spread across the planet
and differentiated genetically,
they produced populations that have
different kinds and amounts of genetic
variation.
Genetic variation for Disease Resistance
has been identified for malaria,
leprosy, HIV, typhoid, fever,
Norwalk virus, prion disease,
and tuberculosis.
The patterns that are now observed could
have been produced both by a loss of
resistance in some groups and
by its acquisition in others.
This can work both ways.
Genetic variation for susceptibility
has been identified for 11 diseases,
including type two diabetes,
biliary liver cirrhosis,
inflammatory bowel disease,
and pancreatic cancer.
Proper treatment will often require
precise determination of an individual's
that genomic state and the current cost
of sequencing that state is about a
thousand to $1,500 so it
is getting within reach.